what were your thoughts on uh
on the whole entire
Drake Elliott Wilson thing and people
saying that Elliot is above doing Run
and Gun interviews and rolling loud you
know I wrestled with that too because
for a long time I would go to Rolling
loud and I would be doing the thing of
standing around and waiting to get
interviews and just trying to you know
finesse just get content yeah and like
you know if you if you get a five minute
conversation with Gunner you just made
your whole trip you know like I went to
you did a young thug one at one of those
yeah and that was the best one that I
ever did and then that's that kind of
killed it for me after that because that
was 2019 and I go to wireless Festival
in London and I get like a 20 minute
Young Thug interview I get like a really
dope juice World Vlog I get Denzel Curry
this is all like in the same day that we
just made like a bunch of fire pieces of
content crazy crazy day crazy day and it
was all because it's in England so
they're not like super they're not
getting pulled in every direction by
their homies there's not a lot of media
and it's not super formal in the sense
that like even young thug has a little
ass like you know like the big as big as
like this table in like the of areas
surrounding it right he's just chilling
like he doesn't have a lot and him there
as opposed to him doing rolling out in
La is a lot different in terms of the
backstage environment who's around him
he's got friends he's got the you know I
remember I went to some random Festival
in Santa Ana like right after that
London one was it the day and night one
yeah and it was just infinitely less
likely that I was going to get any good
content at that you know and like for
somebody like Elliot it's like you
probably remember 2002 he was like the
god of hip-hop media because she was the
editor of double XL and he basically
destroyed the source and he was clicked
up with g in it and Eminem and all this
[__] and I still to this day look at
Elliot I was like just a massive
inspiration in terms of showing me how
it could be done but I Googled it the
other day I think he's like 52 or some
[__] so it is a question of like
does there come a time where you're a
little bit too old or a little bit too
established to be doing the Run and Gun
interviews backstage at rolling loud I
mean I I hope when I'm 52 that I
wouldn't even consider it to be totally
honest I'm 39 now I can still see myself
doing it but I also don't at all so I
don't know I mean like in a perfect
world yeah Elliot Wilson would be like
Jay-Z like where he's just able to like
be this content God and not have to be
in the trenches with the people but at
the same time like you want to be in the
trenches with the people right like
there is an extent to which that's
what's going to keep you young and keep
you in people's minds but I don't really
see myself doing that at 52 but also I
don't I don't judge Elliot for it I feel
like he's still just kind of yeah that's
my thing I think I think it's like it's
like an unfair judgment because I'm sure
he got paid because he was doing
official rolling loud [__] oh it was
four runs it was four rolling loud so
yeah he definitely got a bag for it yeah
and at the end of the day like
everybody's trying to reinvent
themselves like Elliot is he's kind of
gotta I know notice he started
interviewing like a guy like key Glock
which I'm not sure like you know four
years ago he would be interviewing key
clock you know what I'm saying I mean I
haven't watched a lot of Elliot's
interviews over there they're really
good like the Rap Radar podcast is
amazing really okay so I wasn't Drake
one a few years ago I'm not sure I've
seen any since then but like the Drake
one was incredible Flawless for sure you
actually asked him every single thing
that I could imagine you asking they're
very thorough yeah that was amazing to
me I I but I haven't really been super
tuned in yeah yeah for you are do you
even like care to discover new music
anymore like are you still like ear to
the street type guy or if it comes
across your peripherals and you like it
you'll check it it's weird because it's
like the stuff that I like which is like
the Street Music the drill music right
crazy [__] that stuff yeah I'm
constantly finding out about new [__]
because I had a lot of people in my life
that'll be like check out oh five one
kiddo check out Tay Savage check out all
this Chicago [__] or like listen to this
new Bronx drill rapper or whatever so
that stuff it's super easy for me to
stay on top of you know you're talking
about Bia I know she's popular I don't
think I've ever heard her I'm never
gonna like go listen to an R B artist or
like a girl rapper or whatever
realistically like it's just you don't
like r b no no no no well you just got
excited genuine followed you well that's
genuine
so you listen to genuine growing up or
are you more like a januides the guy who
fell off stage come on like that that
comes from the era of me going home from
from school and watching TRL and like
just genuine was on whatever they're
playing right you're watching it like I
I there's a lot of Backstreet Boys songs
that I know every word to unfortunately
that like I'm just never gonna I'm never
gonna see a bunch of you know uh who's
was sort of the K-Pop group BTS
single BTS I love R B I'm r b hits I
love r b but yeah BTS I I couldn't tell
you I keep thinking about because like
the last couple of days I've just been
listening to like all of Dirk's albums
and every single album it's like I could
kind of cut it in half and take all the
soft [__] I was gonna say do you
um are you a big Dirk fan I am a big
Dirk fan okay yeah yeah but if he's
rapping about eyelashes and [__] you
know you want to hear that [__]
whatever no I want to hear kill your Ops
like that's what I'm trying to and I'm
not proud of that it's just like I like
the aggressive songs have are always the
songs that I like yeah yeah you had a
pretty uh dope Derek interview what was
that like 2018 yeah which I didn't like
I knew it was a good interview to get
but it definitely didn't feel like he
was going to be well I think as big as
he is now yeah I think Dirk had like I
think Dirk's got one of those careers
that's like very unique because
he he was on Def Jam forever he was and
like he's evolved into something that
I'm not sure I would have get like you
said in 2018 if somebody would have told
you he's like one of the biggest rappers
in the world you'd been like yeah
I didn't know I didn't I didn't see it
happening but that happens all the time
that there's like artists that I'll
interview and I think they're just super
whatever or I think they're they're good
but like oh yeah he's got like a little
C to potential but if I was a betting
man and you were like I would want 101
odds if I was going to bet 100 bucks on
them you know which is but sometimes
dudes just really go for it and really
work their ass off or or their their
sound that just takes people a while to
catch up to their sound you know